so I wanted to make this video coming
from somebody that's actually been there
that gets you but there is a catch
[Music]
hey everyone welcome to Yesi TV where
you can find weekly videos on minimalism
and healthy living to help you live a
simpler happier life so first things
first I want to make sure that you know
that I'm not making this video to toot
my own horn about how I beat those
anxiety or to belittle it this is
actually incredibly hard for me to put
this out there and for the world to see
because besides my family no one knows
that I was actually seeing a counselor
and then I was diagnosed with social
anxiety but I want to be as transparent
as possible because this channel I
wanted to be founded on transparency
we're gonna have real talk here so make
sure you stuck to the end so you can get
all of my best tips in this video that
being said I first have to explain where
I came from and no I don't mean country
you guys my anxiety was so bad that if I
saw you my best friend of my whole life
in a grocery store or a gas station
I would actually immediately look the
other way and hope that this person did
not see me because my heart was already
pounding my hands were already sweating
and there was a million questions
already in my head what am I gonna say
how I'm gonna start a conversation what
if I look foolish what if I look weird
right now
and
and if you struggle with social anxiety
you know where I'm coming from because
you physically feel it in your body
but this was even with friends not even
just strangers and oh my gosh when I had
to have a phone conversation that was
tortured I had to order food on the
phone I would have rather gone hungry a
million times I had other sorts of
symptoms but enough about me let me know
about you have you ever struggled with
social anxiety let me know in the
comments so kind of knowing where I came
from we can get on to the good stuff tip
number one you are not alone if you
struggle with this you know that there's
constantly a gazillion questions in your
head whether or not people are gonna
like you whether or not you're just
gonna look foolish
I felt like such a loser and I
constantly questioned why I was even
alive because I felt like I had nothing
to offer the world because nobody ever
really knew me but the truth is they
didn't know me because I didn't let them
know me because I was too afraid of
letting them see my vulnerabilities and
this is part of the reason that I'm here
right now I'm letting you know my
vulnerability no you are not a loser and
no you are not the only one social
anxiety disorder is actually quite
common more than 15 million Americans
have it but they're not gonna tell you
about it because they're anxious
tip number two stop comparing yourself
this is truthfully something that I
still struggle with but when we compare
ourselves we are literally destroying
ourselves because we're creating an
expectation it's impossible to live up
to you can only be the best view
possible so don't try to be somebody
else
because the truth is they're not perfect
either and their life may not be as
glamorous as you might think
your story is unique you are unique you
don't need to live someone else's life
because everything that you've been
through till now has made you who you
are and he can either make you stronger
or defeat you and it's up to you tip
number three flip things around when I
was finally diagnosed with social
anxiety I felt such a weight off my
shoulders
not because I was just instantly fixed
with a magic wand but because I knew
that I wasn't alone I knew that this had
a name and that there was something that
I could do about it so instead of seeing
my diagnosis as an excuse to avoid
social events it now became my reason to
go backing out was not an option anymore
I say this just from seeing it in my
family but how many people say I have
depression so I'm not going to exercise
today make it the other way around flip
things around I have depression so I'm
going to exercise I have social
anxieties so I'm going to that party tip
number four get educated two of my
biggest triggers for anxiety were how do
I start the conversation and what did I
do with my weird body language I
constantly shrugged crossed my arms and
avoided eye contact at all cost and I
rarely started a conversation so I got
educated
I took a speech course that was pure
misery I started reading communication
skills books and I also started to
research body language so analyze what
triggers you and what starts those
anxious behaviors that way you can
pinpoint who your enemy is and how
you're going to attack it sounds a bit
odd that we should have to get educated
on how to talk to people but this is an
incredibly important skill so get
educated do your research
learn about body language and
communication I highly recommend one of
my favorite authors youtubers and
behavioural investigator Vanessa van
Edwards she has helped me so much but
before we share that last tip I want you
to take a moment to hit that like button
and subscribe so that you won't miss out
on my videos did you do it yet okay tip
number five practice practice practice
did I say that this was not going to be
fun or easy this is miserable it is
actually torture but the more you expose
yourself to these situations and the
more you expose yourself to meeting new
people and starting conversations the
more you start to realize that hey I
didn't die and it's okay if I look like
a fool it's okay if they don't like me
good study all you want to about how to
have good communication skills and how
to have proper body language but if you
don't put it into practice you will
never improve so you have to fail
remember our motto here is failure is an
opportunity for improvement so get out
there be awkward and repeat and repeat
and repeat until hey that wasn't so bad
I think I can do this
you can do this
I believe in you and I hope you believe
in yourself if you want more positive
mindset tips check out my video how to
be more optimistic and how to eliminate
self-doubt I'll include the links in the
description please don't forget to give
me a like and subscribe so that you
won't miss out on my weekly videos I
thank you so much for staying till the
end and I'm so grateful that you watch
this so get out there be social you can
do this bye
[Music]